سوكا. بوتين في ارض المعركة يحمل
رسالة مرعبة للغرب. واسطول موسكو
النووي على اهبة الاستعداد.
السويد تشعل غضب الدب الروسي
وتتقرب من الناتو والولايات
المتحدة تحدد موعد هجوم اوكرانيا
المضاد. ودولة عربية ترسل بسلاح
لاوكرانيا. التشيك تدوس الخطوط
الحمراء لروسيا والكرملين يرد.
والرجل الاصفر الصين ستوجه ضربة
للولايات المتحدة بمثابة حرب
عالمية. الناتو يتودد للسعودية
وهدنة هشة في السودان والمعارك
طاحنة لليوم الرابع على التوالي.
قوات الاحتلال تواصل جرائمها ضد
الفلسطينيين وواشنطن ترضخ اخيرا
لتركيا وتفي بوعدها. بوتين في
ارض المعركة. لا وقت تضيعه موسكو
وها هي تمضي بخطوات كبيرة على
الاراضي الاوكرانية وبوتين يضع
قدمه على اراضي المعركة حيث ظهر
في محوري خرسون واللوجاسكا اطلع
بوتين على سير العمليات من
القادة العسكريين واستمع الى
التقارير العسكرية وهنأهم بعيد
الفسح. وعلى حين غرة وخلال زيارة
بوتين لمقراته في اوكرانيا اطلقت
السويد تدريباتها التي جمعت فيها
ستة وعشرين الف جندي من اربع
عشرة دولة جلها من الناتو وذلك
في اكبر مناورة عسكرية منذ اكثر
من خمسة وعشرين عاما تحت اسم حيث
لا تزال محاولة البلاد للانضمام
الى الناتو معطلة لتشعل غضب
الروس فكيف سيكون الرد هذه
المرة. الرد الروسي جاء مسبقا.
هنا اسطول روسيا النووي. يصول
ويجول بالمحيط الهادئ والهدف صد
اي هجمات صاروخية معادية. لم
يكتفي بذلك. هنا يعلن الجيش
الروسي ان غواصات بوتين النووية
جاهزة وبحماية من كاسحات الالغام
وبمرافقة سرب من طائرات الحماية
وسرب اخر من الزوارق السريعة
بقيادة القوات البحرية. انها
مسابقة كمال الاجسام النووية فيا
لها من قوة مرعبة. وليس ذلك فحسب
حيث حلقت قاذفتان استراتيجية من
طراز تو نايني فايف ام اس فوق
بحري وذلك بمثابة تحذير من
الرئيس بوتين للغرب بسبب الاحداث
في اوكرانيا. هذا الاحماء
العسكري يحمل رسالة للغرب مفادها
ان اردتم القتال فنحن هنا
والرسالة الاخرى جاءت لاظهار
القوة المرعبة والتي قد ترغم
الغرب للتراجع عن القرارات
والعقوبات بحسب صحيفة ديلي ميل
البريطانية. فهل وصلت الرسالة
الروسية ولكن اوروبا تتجاهل
رسائل بوتين ويغمضون اعينهم
ليدوسوا على خطوط بوتين الحمراء
وذلك باعلان مجلس الوزراء
الالماني عن وصول منظومة الدفاع
الجوي الامريكي باتريوت التي
وعدت بها الحكومة الالمانية
اوكرانيا بل سترد موسكو على هذا
التحرك العسكري. روسيا تواصل
ردودها الحادة تجاه الغرب حيث
استدعت وزارة الخارجية الروسية
سفراء الولايات المتحدة
وبريطانيا وكندا لدى موسكو
تحذرهم وبلهجة شديدة من تدخلهم
الصارخ بشؤون البلاد الداخلية
وذلك بشأن قضية المعارض الروسي
كرامورزا وعلى لسان صاحبة الردود
اللازعة ماريا زاخاروفا والتي
قالت سيتم قمع اي تصرفات
للولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا
وكندا وغيرها من الدول غير
الصديقة والتي تهدف الى اثارة
الفتنة والعداوة في مجتمعنا.
طريقة حاسمة. والدبلوماسيون
المعنيون في هذا العمل سيتم
طردهم من روسيا. لتوجه زاخاروفا
بوصلتها نحو تشيك هذه المرة.
قائلة ان نقل تشيك دبابات مغربية
كانت قيد التحديث لديها الى
منطقة القتال في اوكرانيا انتهاك
فاضح للقوانين الدولية لتجارة
الاسلحة ودليل اخر على المسار
العدائي المعادي لروسيا من جانب
السلطات التشيكية. مستعيرات
الحرب الى مبادرات السلام. حيث
رحب الكرملين بخطة البرازيل التي
تهدف لانهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا
واصفا اياها انها مثيرة
للاهتمام. لكنه لم يرى اي خطة
للسلام تقترحها فرنسا. الرئيس
البرازيلي بدوره طالب الدول غير
المتورطة في الصراع في اوكرانيا
بتحمل مسئولية دفع المفاوضات من
اجل التسوية ولكن اليس غريبا ان
يتجاهل الولايات المتحدة وبشأن
الولايات المتحدة رائحة
التسريبات لم تنتهي. حيث كشفت
صحيفة وول ستريت جورنال ان هناك
جندية امريكية ايضا قد تورطت
بنشرها للوثائق السرية. لتكشف
صحيفة نيوز ويك الامريكية نقلا
عن الوثائق المسربة عن موعد
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد. وبحسب
الصحيفة فان الامدادات والدعم
يتجهان الى اوكرانيا قبل الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد المزمع في
الثلاثين من ابريل الجاري. وان
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
يتطلعون الى المستقبل وهم
مشغولون باعداد اوكرانيا لهذا
الهجوم. وبالعودة الى الحرب
الاوكرانية اعلنت الدفاع الروسية
عن مقتل اكثر من اربعمائة وعشرين
جنديا من الجيش الاوكراني على
مختلف الجبهات خلال اربع وعشرين
ساعة. دوامة السودان لا تنتهي.
الرصاص لم يتوقف والمدافع تدك
معاقل الطرفين. الحرب في السودان
تواصل اشتعالها. ليعلن كل من
قائد الجيش السوداني وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع شبه العسكرية وقف
اطلاق النار وسريان هدنة لمدة
اربع وعشرين ساعة استجابة
لنداءات دولية وظروف انسانية
الهدف منها المرور الامن
للمدنيين واجلاء الجرحى. لكن
اصوات اطلاق نار بالعاصمة
الخرطوم ظلت على حالها توقف برغم
الهدنة بل وحتى اطلاق النار من
الدبابات دوى في الارجاء بحسب
وكالة رويترز. لكن قبل ذلك وعلى
ارض الميدان تواصلت المواجهة
المسلحة في السودان لليوم الرابع
على التوالي. حيث احتدمت المعارك
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع على مشارف القصر الجمهوري
ومركز قيادة الجيش في العاصمة
الخرطوم. بينما حلقت طائرات
حربية في اجواء الخرطوم وقصفت
لقوات الدعم السريع في مطار
مروي. ليعود الجيش السوداني
مجددا ويعلن سيطرته على مطار
مروي مؤكدا هروب قوات الدعم
السريع والتي تحاول تدمير البنية
التحتية. وهناك اصدر الجيش
السوداني قرارا بالعفو عن كل من
يضع السلاح. واي فرد سيسلم سلاحه
سيشمله قرار العفو من جنود الدعم
السريع. المواجهات المنتشرة في
انحاء السودان وصلت حتى المقرات
الاجنبية. حيث قال كبير
دبلوماسيي الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بوئيل ان سفير الاتحاد
الاوروبي في السودان تعرض للهجوم
والاعتداء في منزله بالخرطوم
فلتجدي الهدنة الهشة نفعا بتهدئة
النفوس السودانية ام ان
للمتحاربين رأيا اخر? الاحداث
والتطورات. حذر الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب الملقب
بالرجل الاصفر من تخلي الصين عن
الدولار معتبرا ان ذلك سيكون
بمثابة خسارة الولايات المتحدة
لحرب عالمية. استقبل رئيس النظام
السوري بشار الاسد في القصر
الجمهوري وزير الخارجية السعودي
فيصل بن فرحان والذي وصل الى
دمشق في زيارة رسمية. هل هو
اعلان بعودة سوريا للحاضنة
العربية? امين السعودية تنتهج
سياسة صفر خلافات. اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حي الشيخ
جراح بالقدس المحتلة بحثا منفذ
عملية اطلاق نار حيث قامت
بالاعتداء على عدد من الشبان
وحطمت محتويات البنايات وممتلكات
السكان. كما اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال مسجدا في حي الشيخ جراح
وسط حالة استنفار للقوات
الاسرائيلية وعمليات بحث مكثفة.
اعلنت وكالة التعاون الامني
الدفاعي الامريكية. ان وزارة
الخارجية وافقت على صفقة سلاح
لتركيا بقيمة مائتين وتسعة
وخمسين مليون دولار اسطولها من
طائرات اف ستة عشر. بوتين يواصل
ردوده القوية بتأهب قواته
المدمرة بينما يجوب اراضي الحرب
ليرقب عن كثب الاوضاع الحقيقية
فكيف سيرد الغربيون?